[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález hoy hacemos foco
en guatemala país en donde hay un
creciente malestar ciudadano por
diferentes factores el gran detonante
fue el presupuesto aprobado por el
congreso de guatemala para el año 2021
esto llevó a los ciudadanos a las calles
incluso una parte de la sede del
legislativo fue incendiado ustedes
vieron las imágenes en los informativos
de france 24 finalmente el presidente
del congreso alan rodríguez dio marcha
atrás a esta propuesta escuchemos
a que hemos cumplido con nuestra función
constitucional con la finalidad de
mantener la gobernabilidad del país y la
paz social
hemos acordado suspender el trámite del
presupuesto de ingresos y egresos del
estado y del organismo legislativo para
el periodo 2021 pero la propuesta de
este presupuesto y el disgusto ciudadano
es sólo la gota que llenó y rebasó la
copa a esto también hay que sumarle un
descontento en algunos sectores de la
sociedad guatemalteca sobre la gestión
del presidente alejandro giammatei
también acusaciones de corrupción a su
gobierno y el manejo que el mandatario y
su gobierno le han dado a la crisis
sanitaria provocada por la pandemia del
cob el 19 este país tiene más de 119 mil
casos positivos y más de 4 mil personas
han fallecido a lo largo del 2020 a
causa de la pandemia del cobre 19
incluso hay aparentes divisiones también
al interior del gobierno el
vicepresidente guillermo castillo reyes
le sugirió públicamente al presidente
llamado
y que renunciara aun que renunciaran en
conjunto a sus respectivos cargos esto
fue lo que dijo quiero dejar muy claro
el planteamiento que le he hecho al
presidente por el bien del país que
presentemos ambos nuestra renuncia al
cargo el de presidente y yo de
vicepresidente de la república pero que
lo hagamos juntos con mucha claridad le
he manifestado al señor presidente que
las cosas no están bien que muchos temas
del gobierno y de las decisiones se han
tomado yo no las comparto que no he sido
consultado por la poca comunicación que
tenemos con el señor presidente y que
también obedece a una exigencia
ciudadana que nos han manifestado que
pues las cuestiones no están como se
esperaba como lo decía el gobierno
reverso entonces esta propuesta de
presupuesto ya abrió una mesa de diálogo
para apaciguar los ánimos y también para
buscar acciones contundentes esto fue lo
que dijo el presidente ya mate y en el
establecimiento de esta mesa de diálogo
pero lo importante es que lleguemos al
año entrante con un planteamiento sólido
producto del análisis del diálogo la
concertación y también de algo que a
veces nos hace falta la buena fe esta
invitación al diálogo hecha por el
mandatario es únicamente para tratar
temas relacionados con el presidente con
el presupuesto que tienen hasta el 30 de
noviembre para presentarlo y también
para que sea aprobado de lado entonces
quedan las exigencias por el cierre del
centro de gobierno también la
destitución del ministro de gobernación
y estas señalamientos que hay hacia el
gobierno por la represión ejercida por
las fuerzas de seguridad en las
manifestaciones del 21 de noviembre en
el debate de france 24
guatemala- el estado contra las cuerdas
ese es nuestro tema para analizar
entonces esta situación hemos invitado a
silvia lilian trujillo ella es socióloga
y también comunicadora social nos
atiende desde la ciudad de guatemala y
también está con nosotros iván velázquez
ex jefe de la comisión internacional
contra la impunidad
la recordada como la cicig quien nos
atiende desde la ciudad de bogotá la
capital de colombia les recuerdo que
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación no pueden dejar sus
preguntas y sus comentarios en las redes
sociales se les recuerdo estamos en
facebook y también nos encuentran en
instagram y en twitter como france24
santi logo y la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 pues comenzamos y comienzo
entonces con silvia en ciudad de
guatemala sobre su perspectiva de lo que
está sucediendo allí porque vemos que
esta crisis o por lo menos este malestar
tiene diferentes puntos para analizar
cuál es su perspectiva entonces sobre
este tema
muy buenas tardes a todas ya todos a la
audiencia bueno se registra también el
señor iván velázquez bueno en efecto lo
que estamos viendo en guatemala en la
actualidad es la punta de un ayer porque
esta crisis se ha venido construyendo ya
desde hace varios años y la
manifestación actual heredera quizás de
manifestaciones de años previos pero con
la distinción en la actualidad de que
hay más hartazgo más indignación más
necesidad de expresar el descontento y
es fruto efectivamente de la
imposibilidad de tanto del ejecutivo
como del legislativo de dar respuesta a
las necesidades acuciantes de la
población guatemalteca en la aprobación
en primera instancia el decreto 33 2020
del presupuesto de ingresos y egresos
del estado
pues solamente en la gota digamos que
rebalsó la indigna la indignación pero
como digo esto tiene que entenderse en
el contexto una crisis de largo plazo
que se agudizó primero con cubrir que
luego tuvo que ver con dos tormentas
entraron al territorio guatemalteco como
tormentas tropicales surgieron como
huracanes y que han dejado así que la
mitad del bajo agua y como digo no en el
medio de todo esto que la población está
viviendo y se aprueba este este
presupuesto que es casi un insulto un
insulto para la población y eso es lo
que genera como digo
esta reacción de hecho hubo perdón
enseguida concluyó pero hubo
convocatorias previas a la plaza y no
habían surgido el especto que en efecto
sur-sur
cuando se aprueba este
iván velásquez en la ciudad de bogotá su
opinión al respecto a la situación allí
en guatemala cuál es su perspectiva
no
que coincide en esto es el tema del
presupuesto es sólo en el de tanto
porque en realidad venía una situación
de mucha insatisfacción ciudadana y
muchas omisiones del gobierno tal vez
ciertas negligencias que la población le
atribuía al presidente ya mate y en el
manejo del cob y un gran problema el de
la corrupción una pérdida extraña
todavía no explicada de 135 millones de
quetzales en un ministerio el hallazgo
por parte de la fiscalía especial contra
la impunidad
de 122 millones de quetzales en efectivo
en la casa de un ex ministro del ex
presidente jimmy morales el ministro de
comunicación entonces todo
ha venido generando una gran
insatisfacción que fue lo que estalló
[Música]
con el tema del presupuesto
silvia ya vemos el panorama entre
ustedes dos han armado el rompecabezas
de la situación allí que es bastante
complicado son diferentes frentes como
ustedes mismos lo han explicado que
puede pasar entonces en guatemala porque
los ciudadanos no están conformes con la
institucionalidad no creen en la
institucionalidad de este gobierno está
rechazando algunas de las políticas de
este presidente del presidente alejandro
giammatei no les gusta el manejo que le
han dado a la pandemia
tampoco les ayuda a la situación después
de la pandemia el paso de los huracanes
que rumbo entonces puede tomar guatemala
para poder cambiar la situación que se
está presentando allí
bueno en efecto también hay distintas
perspectivas una que tiene que ver
específicamente con el rumbo del
presupuesto porque a pesar de que el
legislativo o la junta directiva
legislativo dio marcha atrás en realidad
esto hay que analizarlo con un poco más
de detenimiento porque no está la
solución todavía es decir lo que puede
suceder ahora es que sea una estrategia
dilatoria para que finalmente persista
este presupuesto o el presupuesto del
año anterior
que también están basados en deuda
pública de manera tal que aunque se dio
marcha atrás insisto esto no ha resuelto
el problema particular de del
presupuesto paralelamente a esto hay
otra vez todo el descontento generado
con las acciones de legislativo y en
respuesta a eso y bueno por un lado se
sigue convocando a las protestas en el
espacio público continuas hoy hubo
varias protestas y se está convocando
nuevamente al sábado a la plaza como le
llamamos pero hay una propuesta de lo
que ha surgido de la asamblea popular y
bueno ha sido acortada por diferentes
sectores de convocar un diálogo amplio y
ya la construcción de un estado
plurinacional y paritario antipatriarcal
con características más plurales digamos
por ahora es todo demasiado incipiente
como digo estamos tratando de
conceptualizar o de teorizar sobre la
marca
si efectivamente ya los sectores
populares se han dado cuenta que las
protestas masivas del 2015 en algún
sentido el sistema encontró la forma de
refuncionalizar las y de transformarlas
nuevamente en propuestas dentro del
sistema y entonces por eso decía que
ahora hay una sensación una percepción
distinta de la necesidad de politizar
las propuestas que surjan del campo
popular
interesante perspectiva silvia desde
ciudad de guatemala señor velázquez iván
velázquez en la ciudad de bogotá
aquí notamos un hartazgo por parte de
los guatemaltecos no es solamente por
los hechos recientes como ya lo decíamos
esto el presupuesto ha sido la gota que
ya llegó al borde de la copa lo veíamos
en las elecciones presidenciales
anteriores donde la participación
ciudadana fue muy baja para elegir al
nuevo presidente hay un descontento
generalizado hacia la clase política y
hacia el manejo que le han dado al país
está guatemala al borde de caer en un
círculo de protestas como hubo por
ejemplo en chile o en perú que llevaron
a la caída del gobierno en perú
simplemente porque hay un descontento
generalizado entre los entre los
habitantes
yo creo que es posible porque es que en
realidad son muchos los los factores
la dificultad de los problemas por los
que atraviesa y si hay por ejemplo
respecto de la corte suprema desde hace
más de un año el congreso debió elegir a
los nuevos magistrados
pero lo ha hecho esto fue algo que
también irritó a la población como
tramitan un presupuesto de la manera
como lo hicieron de urgencia nacional
con una rapidez extraordinaria pero
llevan un año sin elegir magistrados de
la corte suprema de justicia y un gran
rechazo a la corte suprema de justicia
porque ha amparado y protegido a
diputados corruptos a los que no les ha
levantado la inmunidad y por el
contrario
ha accedido a levantar la inmunidad a
magistrados de la corte de
constitucionalidad que han estado firmes
en la defensa del estado de derecho
entonces todo esto respecto del poder
judicial con el legislativo el tema de
el presidente la creación que mencionaba
silvia del centro de gobierno que además
le quita las funciones desplazó
absolutamente al vicepresidente así como
lo presentaron ustedes en la en la nota
introductoria
el vicepresidente no tiene comunicación
con el presidente de la república está
sin funciones lo que es inusual en
guatemala que siempre hay una
distribución de funciones entre el
presidente y el vicepresidente hay
además esa sensación de una gran
corrupción que yo creo que después de lo
ocurrido en el 2015 y de las grandes
manifestaciones del 2015 este tema de la
corrupción es algo que para los
guatemaltecos se va convirtiendo en algo
insoportable y que va a alimentar mucho
todas estas protestas y unido a eso el
manejo tan inadecuado que se le dio a la
protesta pacífica del 21 la represión
que se que se hizo contra la población
entonces todo esto ha generado también
una mayor insatisfacción una
una rabia adicional lo que finalmente no
está ni siquiera aclarado cómo fue esto
del incendio en el congreso siempre está
bastante custodiado toda la zona del
centro de la ciudad de la plaza de la
constitución del congreso de la casa
presidencial pero para el 21 no había
seguridad y hay bastantes sospechas que
si ese incendio fue realmente provocado
por manifestantes o eran infiltrados con
alguna otra pretensión precisamente para
deslegitimar una manifestación que se
salía desde hace varios días que iba a
ser multitudinaria como en efecto lo fue
silvia a mí me llama la atención que
dentro de este malestar y esta crisis
que está empezando a desarrollarse allí
en guatemala de uno al presidente al
presidente ya me está teniendo problemas
de comunicación como menciona iván con
su vicepresidente se nota hay un
rompimiento que tan acompañado esta
llama 'the y para poder hacer frente a
esta crisis
poco a poco se está empezando a quedar
solo para hacer frente a esta situación
como lo ve usted
bueno en efecto se está quedando con
quienes lo han apoyado desde que asumió
es una parte del sector empresarial y
los sectores más oscuros es
del país es decir hoy por ejemplo este
llamado supuesto a una mesa para
analizar el presupuesto una mesa donde
asistieron las cámaras entonces
en efecto
[Música]
y la reacción del presidente
justamente como lo planteaban algunos
analistas en el día de hoy es la
reacción porque en efecto se va viendo
cómo se le van cercenando los pollos y
como digo el deslegitimado su llamado al
diálogo deslegitimado además que él hace
antes del llamado al diálogo una carta
se apela a la carta democrática
interamericana diciendo que en guatemala
estamos al borde de un rompimiento del
orden constitucional con la única prueba
de las grandes y masivas protestas que
ha habido en este país
entonces es decir no se llama a un
diálogo después de haberle escupido la
cara a la persona con la que se quiere
dialogar un diálogo se forma con
personas que están en simetría si no no
es un diálogo es un soliloquio y éstas
llama estos llamados estos intentos
desesperados en el ejecutivo de
supuestos insisto mesas para analizar
cuando esto ya está consumado
e insisto analizar con los sectores que
lo han defendido
y llaman mucho la atención la materia en
su gobierno ha sido cuestionado incluso
desde la campaña por tener cercanía con
personas cuestionadas incluso personas
que hoy están cumpliendo cárcel por
delitos graves por haberse quedado con
dinero impuestos
bueno en fin ha sido cuestionado por uso
de dinero durante la campaña ha sido
cuestionado por tener vínculos con
sectores militares muy cuestionados en
este país
y como digo en efecto y ahora la
relación que definitivamente está
cortada con el vicepresidente de la
reforma
señor velásquez esta mesa de diálogo que
ha instaurado y ha impulsado el
presidente llama 'the y se enfocó
solamente en el tema del presupuesto
porque tienen hasta el 30 de noviembre
para tener algún tipo de respuesta por
parte del congreso si es que lo aprueban
o no si se quedan con él con el
presupuesto del 2020 para continuar en
el 2021 pero en esta mesa de diálogo se
ignoraron todos los temas solamente se
enfocaron en los gastos que tienen
justificados para el año entrante y
dentro de esos gastos uno ve una enorme
cantidad de dinero para unos proyectos
de infraestructura que están amparados
por el ministerio de comunicaciones que
ha sido fuertemente acusado de muchos
casos de corrupción que usted debe
conocer muy bien algunos de estos casos
y una disminución e incluso poca
inversión en temas como salud y
educación que son las prioridades que
los ciudadanos sienten que es lo que
guatemala tiene que hacer frente en este
momento la educación y la salud porque
obviamente estamos en la mitad de una
pandemia a nivel mundial cómo entender
que el presidente propone eso tiene
entonces bajo la manga
repartir este dinero ya en casos de
corrupción adelantémonos a posibles
escenarios similares a los que ya ha
vivido el país en el pasado donde la
plata se pierde en proyectos que nunca
tienen lugar y nunca realizan
sí pues aquí hay hay varios elementos de
un lado la convocatoria a esa reunión en
realidad no fue atendida por amplios por
por todos los sectores los que podríamos
denominar sectores más independientes
como como así es por ejemplo una una ong
guatemalteca un centro de pensamiento
no sé no se hizo presente es una reunión
prácticamente entre amigos la la iglesia
evangélica que resultó una situación tan
tan extraña que se convoca la iglesia
evangélica para discutir el presupuesto
pero además ya sobre la base del humor
legalidad porque es que esto
por supuesto que se aprobó hubo un trans
lo que correspondía era pasar al
presidente de la república quien debía
vetarlo ahora simplemente por una
decisión de junta directiva
algo que ya está aprobado por 115
diputados quedan sin efecto esta es una
gran ilegalidad en el parc ya sé si me
permite un momento santiago me parece
muy similar esta situación a la que se
vivió a principios del año 2015
en el 2003 sí
venid y guía
n en una gran población pero de la que
había bastante cuestionamiento bastante
sospecha sobre actividades de corrupción
que después se se acreditaron
pero se niega al sol de prensa o el
rumor público pero con un hecho
particular de lo que se conoció en
guatemala como la uita mágica
una mezcla de agua con sal no sé qué
elementos para descontaminar un lago muy
cercano de la ciudad y capital el lago
amatitlán y la
poblaciones estaba con música
cuando la asiste con la fiscalía
especial contra la impunidad
presentaron el caso que se conoció como
de la línea al presidente entonces voto
carisma
otto pérez molina molina
son realmente gigantesca cuál fue la
situación ahora frente a un presupuesto
en el que como los en usted
se disminuyen o no se consideran gastos
de inversión necesarios de inversión
social en salud en educación el gran
problema de la desnutrición de los niños
tercos pero simultáneamente hay un
incremento en las asignaciones para el
consumo de alimentos por los diputados
en las sesiones y entonces 200 millones
que no se destinan para la niñez son
millones que se destinan para el confort
de los diputados y hasta percibió
directamente la población y tal vez fue
uno de los hechos más generadores de la
indignación ciudadana
un caso importante y gracias por estos
detalles iván velázquez desde ciudad de
bogotá desde la ciudad de bogotá en
colombia dando los detalles de
diferentes casos
que se han visto allí de corrupción
silvia es
como los guatemaltecos pueden ejercer
presión a las autoridades a la
institucionalidad frente a este tipo de
casos porque ya lo vemos es algo
prácticamente una forma cómo funcionan
los estados en américa latina' la
corrupción está de por medio para el
funcionamiento los guatemaltecos qué
instrumentos tienen para defender este
tipo de reclamos como estos gastos de
dinero en otros en otros proyectos
pues lamentablemente la única opción que
estamos teniendo en este país en los
últimos tiempos es la protesta masiva
porque en el sistema de partidos
políticos y la ley electoral que tenemos
ha sido muy complicada y la esté
modificando resulta un poco complejo y
siempre estamos pensando en cada
elección estamos pensando en votar al
menos peor de los candidatos ya por
ejemplo en este momento ya se están
diciendo quiénes van a ser los
candidatos y lamentando y en base del
candidato ganador
entonces el sistema político está en una
grave crisis lleva en esta crisis en un
tiempo prolongado
por eso les llamado a la constitución de
un estado plurinacional y con otras
características porque así como está
cortado por el pacto de corruptos es muy
complicado en el 2017 los diputados
también hicieron la intentona
completamente anti popular
el congreso fue rodeado por la
ciudadanía y tuvieron que darle marcha
atrás de la misma forma que y ahora
entonces
como digo en el corto plazo lo que nos
queda es la protesta por qué
como digo no estamos pensando estamos
tratando de forzar la discusión política
pero yo ha sido un proceso muy
complicado guatemala es un país con
guerra por una democracia muy endeble
con un estado que es fuerte para
defender los intereses de las empresas
extractivas pero débil para responder a
las necesidades de la ciudadanía
entonces con una educación pública
absolutamente paupérrima por eso indigna
tanto este seguro escolar que al que en
este presupuesto se designaban 330
millones con seguro escolar para unas
escuelas públicas que no expone a que
existen pero algunas están sin techo
algunas no tienen bancos las y los niños
estudian en este país en condiciones
terribles y si no hay dinero para pagar
la educación privada
pues simple y llanamente la gente se
queda sin acceder a la educación es
decir por eso digo que es muy complicado
pensar en estas condiciones con una
sociedad que ha tenido tan pocas
oportunidades pensar que iba a ser por
medio de los lo que permite el sistema
político por lo menos en el corto plazo
y van silvia plantea la protesta
ciudadana como el mecanismo más fuerte
para poder ejercer presión y ejercer
presión en el gobierno alejandro
giammatei leyendo un poco la prensa
local muchos han señalado estas
manifestaciones por estar infiltradas
por grupos de izquierda por grupos que
en su momento estuvieron un poco al
margen de la ley y han criticado a este
tipo de protestas porque en américa
latina' se desacredita siempre la
manifestación ciudadana cuando se está
en contra de estos casos de corrupción
de estos de estos lineamientos
gubernamentales que muchas veces los
ciudadanos pueden no estar de acuerdo
porque allí en guatemala el escenario
también es similar
porque es la forma como desde el poder
se pretende deslegitimar la
la movilización ciudadana la mejor
manera es la acusación de ser
terroristas ni siquiera a la izquierda
sino terroristas pero ya vimos en el
propósito que había de criminalizar la
protesta a las decisiones de los jueces
respecto de los 30 cerca de 39 tal vez
detenidos que hubo el 21 de noviembre
todos los jueces dieron libertad no
aceptaron las imputaciones de la
fiscalía por por falta de mérito
entonces es una manera por eso decía que
anotaba lo del incendio y precisamente
en algunas de las imágenes que que
acaban de pasar
presencia de policía nacional civil
dentro del congreso como lo mostró un
medio de comunicación está tal vez en el
día de hoy estaban dentro del congreso
antes de producirse el incendio no
tendría que ver o la desprotección del
congreso si fue un acto de omisión o el
incendio esa imagen precisamente de ola
o la omisión
o una actividad real para tratar de
atribuirle esto al movimiento y
deslegitimarlo esos son de las grandes
inquietudes aquí hay un problema muy
complicado para el país yo creo que la
la afectación que se produjo
particularmente con los tres últimos
años del presidente anterior el
presidente morales que públicamente le
invitó a desconocer decisiones de la
corte de constitucionalidad que no acató
decisiones de la corte de
constitucionalidad eso ha producido
también un resquebrajamiento de
legitimidad en el país o en este
gobierno tanto como en el anterior que
se hacen condiciones en el congreso de
la república con un partido que huye ex
embajador de eeuu en guatemala
señalaba como un partido del
narcotráfico y cuyo jefe prácticamente
el propietario porque guatemala los
partidos tienen dueño está preso en
estados unidos por narcotráfico acusado
señalado igualmente no acusado porque
eso no se ha investigado en guatemala
pero señalado de haberle pedido a unos
supuestos narcotraficantes mexicanos que
en realidad eran agentes de la dea que
van dieran muerte a la ex fiscal
y todo esto yo creo que muestra que la
situación de guatemala es realmente muy
complicada muy complicada son muchas
aristas para analizar y se me acaba el
tiempo para el programa es silvia como
ve usted el escenario a futuro qué va a
pasar continúa el gobierno acepta en el
presupuesto más manifestaciones cuales
en la bolita de cristal digámoslo así
que usted ve en cuanto a la situación en
guatemala
bueno el presupuesto hay tres escenarios
posibles pero pero bueno va a haber va a
haber que esperar sinceramente por
ejemplo que la corte se pusiera a la
corte de constitucionalidad se pudiera
pronunciar porque si no los otros dos
escenarios con que finalmente nos
quedamos con éste o con el anterior que
son igual de malos porque tienen que ver
con deuda pública
probablemente una persistencia en el
tiempo de las manifestaciones y de las
protestas porque como digo la
indignación no cesa y el presidente con
una imagen pública ende se tensó cada
vez más cuestionado cada vez más porque
sus decisiones
en efecto tocan puntos neurales
yo no avisoró un escenario en calma por
lo menos en los próximos meses es
probable que las protestas
vayan oscilando y que haya digamos en
algunas no es la cantidad de personas
que hubo probablemente el sábado pero
hay una como digo un proceso sostenido
de manifestaciones desde el 2015 en el
2017 y nuevamente en la actualidad si
antes no sabe ahora que la
conflictividad generada por este
gobierno quiere decir que en eso vaya a
acceder y van rápidamente quedan 40
segundos de programa su conclusión que
sigue aquí en adelante
creo que va a seguir la protesta
ciudadana y que el gobierno si actuar
racionalmente tiene que sentarse a
dialogar pero para la transformación no
para simplemente y aplacar sino para
transformar muchas gracias
silvia trujillo iván velázquez por haber
estado con nosotros aquí en el debate
france24 haber compartido con nosotros
sus opiniones en torno a esta crisis
política en guatemala ustedes gracias
por la sintonía pueden continuar dejando
sus comentarios y preguntas en las redes
sociales sigan con nuestra programación
[Música]